[Music]
we've quantified your digital footprint
so that you can see the impact you've
had on the Internet oh hi my name is
markiplier and this is the data of me
this is what happens when you google
markiplier okay 49 I don't don't see 49
million results Google always says that
but I don't think that's true at all
at Google myself everyday one section
that comes up is people also ask can you
answer these questions is markiplier
half Korean yes on my mom's side what
happened to team applier Oh moved on to
other things
does markiplier have a child god no you
think I could be responsible for a baby
no way
how old is markiplier is dog chica she
is four and a half years old such a
young lady what is markiplier famous for
nothing absolutely squat diddly can I
curse on this diddly I don't know
according to Google people also search
for these five other people can you
guess who they are probably
jacksepticeye PewDiePie the diamond
minecart or dantdm Ethan jacksepticeye
got it nailed it PewDiePie nailed it I'm
killing it March
marzia what's yet oh there's dantdm and
vanossgaming
I guess that makes sense I haven't
talked to the guy in a while they also
searched for these other people oh okay
this just makes sense these are just
other youtubers this is a Google Trends
graph of your name searched over time oh
it's spelling out the doom of my channel
well I can see the peak here early 2015
is that one four five nights at freddys
first came out 2015 Oh emergency surgery
long story short my adrenal gland big
tumor had to get it out I had a
complication from that scar tissue
cinched off part of my intestine I had
to get people in there and cut it all
out I'm fine
it looked real sad and real scary
because I had a tube down my nose and
down my throat into my stomach I was
getting my stomach pumped like I looked
in a bad way so I'm assuming people
thought I was dying but I was fine
let's see be those Daniel Carr he's a
good friend of mine partisan ago we
worked together yeah it was a real dark
time all right number C diamond clay but
wow I can't believe that was a
monumental enough event for that to
actually be a thing
I guess I'm flattered it's broken I
actually have no idea where my diamond
play button is right now oh yeah that's
not good this is your name searched over
just the last year I don't know was it
is it good is it bad hit twenty million
oh that was the nude calendar we raised
half a million from the nude calendar I
had to sign 30 something thousand
calendars cuz I promised I'd sign every
one of them eight days with nothing but
signing I would just go to the warehouse
where we were shipping them out from and
I would just sign put on headphones to
sign do nothing but that oh the six I
went on tour oh I know it's a break from
YouTube what then wait a minute
look alright my my niece Miranda she had
a car accident and she passed away now
I'm actually kind of shocked that none
of these are about five nights at
freddys it's good in a way it's more
about just me as a person and my story
Google Trends also shows related queries
here are the top three cloak Mark Blair
cloak is my clothing brand very good
stuff big brain time markiplier okay
this was another meme my editor just
made an edit of me with a big ol head
and I said hi this big brand time as
something so stupid and so fast but then
I don't know people blew it up I still
don't understand the II mean but
whatever big chunks that has nothing to
do with me big chunks is like this
editor someone there was like a Bugs
Bunny thing where he was making fun of
Elmer Fudd er dive
it was but it's an old old screenshot
from Bugs Bunny and then people just
copy that image and put the text big
chunks over it and yeah you got yourself
a meme I don't know but it's nothing to
do with me we went to Getty and when
it's sorted by oldest damage this from
October 2016 comes up yeah this is a
Streamy Awards I'm not really into word
shows or anything like that but this is
like bread round the corner for me so I
was like yeah let's show up whatever
pointless I didn't win whatever these
are your most viewed videos on YouTube
yeah I know what they are five nights at
Freddy's five guys two Freddy's animated
meow something like that I don't know my
mix of Freddy's five nights at Freddy's
animated me I nailed it
yes we collected all the comments from
those videos and made a word cloud
charity and what inspire happy and bit
like it's just that's really cool ankle
oh it's because of this ankle yeah I
don't know why that would be like a
popular word but yeah I can do that
I don't know it's stupid but people like
it can you guess how many upload
subscribers and video views you haven't
generated uploads like somewhere 4500
something like that
45 27 I was pretty close subscribers
it's like 24 million six hundred
thousand as of this video twenty four
point five it's actually twenty four
point six but I know that YouTube's
abbreviated things so it's hard to get a
real number video views we just crossed
12 billion recently high smooth marker
blah got me over there like across all
the videos like it's got it's got right
now over ten million on the first video
if you add up all of them it's like over
100 million views yeah so I am over 12
billion now while playing a total of
1476 games you counted get a wife as
weird over this time period you
developed 20 fan loved personas how many
can you name wolf or worse - dark
applier at Edgar
Google plier or BIM trimmer I've got
some new ones in heist I don't know if
you're counting those but I'm assuming
you're not Santa
if plier what can't Bing okay I give up
how many okay Wilfred Wharf sash dark
applier Santa Claus mm trimmer and Edgar
silver silver Shepherd of course a lot
of these are actually characters that I
collaborated with cyndago on and a lot
of them are like their characters more
than they're my characters doctor eat
the air Google plier copyright like its
lawsuit waiting to happen
Bing also problem king of the squirrels
forgot about that
king of snap that's not really a persona
that's just who I am the mark bottom
that's not a real person
Shea who Shane Walsh what is that
Shaitan I've never heard of it that's
not a thing that's not a thing marquee
move that's just a nickname there dude
you're dipping into the bottom of the
barrel here Hershel Greene Oki Hershel
yeah Sally mix agate it's that was just
my username to bump off that's my
username not list is grab mark Blair fan
60 yeah this is all crap this is the
garbage list written by hacks
there are 1163 unique hashtags on
Instagram associated with markiplier a
few of them caught our attention there
is so tiny
markiplier saved me markiplier
pole-dancing that's a good one I didn't
pull that see videos you didn't see
those at all you're digging through my
channel this some of the most popular
ones people love those actually do more
markiplier for president I'm not old
enough we found your account on tilt fi
and the top three amounts for charity
raised can you tell us why you picked
these charities mark Blair youth
homeless that was my 24 hour livestream
to raise half a million it was some
pie-in-the-sky goal I can't believe we
did it
I was actually gonna go 48 hours we got
it in 24 which is nuts Save the Children
that was something I did
with the boys Tyler and Nathan and also
Amy and Katherine were behind the scenes
helping out with that and Evan I think
was helping out I mean it just seemed
like a great cause
market leras march charity livestream
charity water I want to do things that
were like tangibly gonna help someone
not that like going towards research and
stuff like that isn't creating tangible
help but this is helping people directly
this is helping kids directly this is
helping youth homelessness directly I
like those because you can really feel
the benefit that comes out of it and
this isn't all the streams I've ever
done this is just what I've done with
tilta Phi but even so like it's it's so
cool to see that there's a history to it
that you can see what was done with it
that you can see where this came from
I like the end what do I think I've left
my mark on the internet if I were to die
tomorrow I guess I could be pretty happy
with what I've done I don't know I've
just always had a philosophy that I
wanted to leave the world a better place
and I found it I don't know if I've done
that yet but I'll keep working towards
it
[Music]